all right so I'm gonna continue to talk
about this intimate relationship between
aerosols
and climate sensitivity um Steve and and
Chris stole some of my thunder but
that's that's okay I think it's this
topic is important enough that we can we
can hear about it a few times the
economists in the room may recognize
some economists here in the co-author
list here and so towards the end of of
my talk I'll get to collaborative
project that we've done with support of
the yci but before that I'll talk about
generally how aerosols can affect
climate and then move on to talk about
this relationship between aerosols and
climate sensitivity that we've already
heard a little bit about earlier today
and then I'll talk about this new
approach that we've taken and I look
forward to having feedback on those very
recent results all right so I thought it
would be appropriate in the geology and
geophysics Department to start by
talking about the effect that we saw
from aerosol submitted by the volcanic
eruption from Mount Pinatubo in 1991 and
I think it's a very nice example of how
powerful aerosol effects on climate can
be this is a study by Brian Soudan and
co-workers in 2002 so at the top here
see yeah the top here we have
observations in black and three
realizations of the GFDL model and this
is showing the cooling as a result of
the eruption which the eruption is
indicated here on the timeline and you
can see that we got a cooling from that
eruption from the aerosols that were
emitted from the volcanic eruption of
more than half a degree C and that
cooling persisted for several years and
the reason it could do so was that the
the eruption was so explosive that it
put aerosol particles all the way up to
in the stratosphere where aerosol
particles can have long lifetimes in the
atmosphere
the study was also a nice test of one of
the major feedback mechanisms in our
climate system the water vapor feedback
and and soda and co-workers could test
our model compared to observations here
four column water vapor and changes in
response to the cooling and also upper
tropospheric water if a changes and it
appears that this model anyway got got
the water vapor feedback right and that
was that water vapor feedback was
central and reproducing the cooling from
the volcanic eruption now zooming out
quite a bit we have the temperature
record for the last hundred and fifty
years or so and I've indicated that
cooling from Mount Pinatubo here it
doesn't look as impressive in this
temperature record what you can also
note is the so called hiatus which I
believe the next speaker will talk more
about that hiatus goes away when you
look at dakedo averages instead of
annual data as we have on top here and
you can argue that looking at decadal
average this is perhaps the appropriate
thing to do for for climate change for
the for the scales that were interested
in what doesn't go away though is this
height is from the 1950s to roughly the
1980s or you could even argue that there
was a temporal temporary cooling at that
time and we think that that was related
to the amount of aerosols that we were
emitting into the atmosphere at that
time so we can look at indirect evidence
for that being the case we can look at
the part of the radiation spectrum that
that aerosol particles influence so what
I'm showing here is for different time
periods and for different parts of the
world I'm showing trends in downward
solar radiation at the surface as an
indirect evidence that this was the
cooling was caused by aerosols so you
see that from the 1950s to the 1980s
when we had this period of cooling that
coincided with this period of so-called
global dimming where we had a downward
trend in incoming solar radiation at the
surface then in around 1980 we had
distance
session 2 what has been called global
brightening at least in in the US and in
Europe you can see that the global
dimming continued very much in in parts
of Asia and then after the 2000 we the
the brightening has continued but in
China there's now dimming again and the
dimming and India's also continued so we
can compare that to trends in emitted
sulfur sulfur goes on to form sulfate
particles in the atmosphere and so that
so there Center for central for the
Arizona Arizona effects attribute ending
aerosol effects oh sorry so you can see
that we had this period where we were
emitting a lot of sulfur globally from
the 1950s to the 1980s and then we had
this period where the emissions weren't
really going up and that this is when we
had this transition from dimming to
brightening and now they've actually
started going down however if this
figure had can continued into the
present we would have seen that there's
a local minimum actually in in red right
around the year 2000 and and the
emissions have increased again since
then and that increase comes in almost
entirely from emissions from China so oh
the numbers yeah the numbers are come
this is from a paper by Martin Wells and
and he had the units are in watts per
meter square but he had compiled that
from a number of other other papers that
had looked at this all right
so quickly here are some some very
recent schematics from the new IPCC
report to just remind everyone how
aerosols can affect climb it's so
scattering aerosols have a cooling
effect by reflecting more sunlight back
to space and they have a cooling effect
both locally and on a larger scale but
there are also air cells that can absorb
solar radiation and they have a local
cooling effect at the surface but for
the entire system and on on a larger
scale that
actually I have a warming effect and
then aerosols can also influence clouds
they tend to brighten clouds by forming
more cloud droplets and so you increase
the cloud albedo and that corresponds to
a cooling also so now looking at how
these aerosols aerosol effects have
impacted the the radiation budget since
pre-industrial times we're now looking
at from the old IPCC report the
radiative forcings between 1850 and the
present uh I I prefer the old figure for
many reasons one is that I like that the
the warming the positive force things
are the warming's are color color coated
with warm colors and the Cooling's have
blue colors which i think is nice and
and so so I wanted to bring your
attention to the the numbers associated
with the direct and indirect aerosol
effects here so the the scattering and
absorption of solar radiation here and
the fact of clouds here and and now
moving on to the newest IPCC report the
forcing look the forcing diagram looks
something like this and so you can then
look at the same forcing numbers from
from the direct and indirect aerosol
effect and you can see that they've
they've come down quite a bit since the
last IPCC report I always find it
interesting that that with the direct
effect we seem to have a high level of
confidence about this effect but it
turns out we don't really even know what
sign it has I'm not sure how you can
have a high level of confidence about
something that you don't know the sign
of really but that's that may be
semantics anyway the the you can see
that the the error bars associated with
the the total total forcing of climate
since pre-industrial times a lot of
those error bars come from the error
bars associated with these aerosol
effects and so they are they are very
uncertain
the fact that there's the total aerosol
effect is thought to be somewhat lower
now than in the previous report it has
allowed for a lowering of the range of
climate sensitivities that that came out
of that report and so I I'm I'm going to
now move on to a figure that started as
a bizarre or maybe a pathetic hobby of
mine a while back when I was a graduate
student I started to plot estimates of
the aerosol effect that came out in the
literature as a function of the
publication year and and by now it's
become a monster of a figure but each
each circle here essentially represents
a paper and the estimates that came out
of that paper and I put shadings in here
to show what people think is really
compatible with the kind of warming we
have this so that's sort of the
constraint that has become more and more
clear is that the total Arizona fact has
to be smaller in 92 than minus 2 watts
per meter square so for the for the
aerosol indirect effect in the previous
figure that would the best estimate for
that was point 55 watts per meter
squared so that would be somewhere up
here so you can see that most of the
estimates in the literature are actually
in magnitude are much larger and than
that and the fact that that the the
estimate in the new IPCC chart is so low
I think is related that to the fact that
they put a lot of weight on on satellite
estimates that have their own issues but
I wanted to bring it bring in the the
point that actually most of the
estimates that are in the literature
give a higher or stronger aerosol effect
than what goes into the IPCC charge all
right so there's all effect is uncertain
and and that's a problem for for us when
we try to constrain climate sensitivity
and and this was brought to people's
attention by Andy and
in a paper of his in 2005 the title that
was strong person take aerosol [ __ ]
implies hot hot future so we've seen
some version of this equation before it
simply relates the radiative forcings
since pre-industrial times to the
present to the observed temperature
change times the radiative forcing
associated with a doubling of co2 and
this is essentially the climate
sensitivity the temperature change for a
doubling of co2 and then there's the
ocean heat uptake over here that also is
going to be addressed in the in the
following talk I believe and so you can
see that well since since Delta T is
measured and known and we know what the
radiative forcing associated with
doubling of co2 is if we if for a given
ocean heat uptake we get this inverse
relationship between the the total
radiative forcing and the climate
sensitivity so a large aerosol forcing
large negative aerosol forcing brings
down the the total radiative forcing and
brings up the climate sensitivity and
that's what Andy Andrews showed in this
figure here where if we have a strong
aerosol cooling presently that implies a
very high climate sensitivity and for a
given these were the old old emission
scenarios so for a given emission
scenario if we had a strong air so
cooling in fact presently that would
give us a warming by 2100 of of 8
degrees C which is quite quite
frightening on the other hand if we had
a very weak or even no aerosol cooling
effect presently that would give a much
more moderate warming so that was one of
the the perhaps earlier studies that
brought attention to this issue of the
the strong coupling between the aerosol
effect and how it relates to the total
forcing and how it relates to to climate
sensitivity I'm gonna skip that figure
because I think it's very similar to
what Steve showed so then a couple years
later Jeff keel published a paper
where he looked at this relationship in
global climate models and I want to skip
back now and say that he used this
equation here to come up with the curves
in the in the figure here to say what
the what a theoretical relationship
between climate sensitivity and the
total forcing will be according to that
equation and then he picked a few
numbers for for ocean heat uptake for H
and then he he plotted for I believe 9
global climate models he plotted that on
top of these theoretical lines and he
found that these 9 global climate models
fit quite well with that that
theoretical relationship and and on the
right hand side here is just it just
shows that what we already know well is
that the total forcing is really
controlled by what the aerosol forcing
is so when people saw this they took
this as evidence that climate modelers
are cheating because really you can you
can reproduce the temperature record
with any kind of climate sensitivity
really as long as you pick the right
aerosol forcing to go with it and and
and and that's that's true if you mean
the aerosol forcing at this point is so
poorly constrained that why wouldn't you
pick an aerosol forcing that allows you
to reproduce the temperature record of
the past because you could argue that a
very simple test the first test that you
would put a climate model through is
whether it can we produce the observed
temperature record and and in fact that
was the question that Jeff keel was
asking in this paper he said how come
all these models with all these
different climate sensitivities can all
reproduce the temperature record of the
past well they can do so by just picking
the aerosol forcing that allows them to
do so so that's problematic right it's
problematic that we can't can't
constrain the aerosol forcing better
because that is really what causes the
the climate models to come up with all
these different estimates for climate
sensitivity well this was is an old
study by now and people have made
similar figures for the
the model simulations from from cmip5
Wow the simulations that went into
seemeth 5 and you can actually recognize
the the numbers or the the curve and the
the dots that went into the Akhil figure
here in red and there's a correlation
coefficient R square going going into
that as well they did the same thing now
to see how the Sima Phi models fit with
the this these this theoretical
relationship and and and they published
this since they said look climate models
modelers aren't really cheating because
see that they're not following these
curves anymore
well then they said if you take the
subset of models that are actually able
to reproduce the temperature record of
the past to within ninety percent
uncertainty range those are the the the
symbols here that are highlighted in
green so all the other models really
couldn't the black diamonds here are now
from the seam of five modeling archive
all these other models couldn't really
reproduce the temperature record and the
ones that could still fall on this line
meaning the models that we produced a
temperature record are still you know
compensating you know if they have a
high climate sensitivity they need to
have small forcing meaning a large
negative aerosol forcing so this is
still true so how do you mean how do we
make progress you know the common models
haven't been really able to constrain
the aerosol effect and therefore we they
they haven't been able to constrain
equilibrium climate sensitivity better
either and so that's where this uh-oh
sorry and I wanted to actually I'll skip
that so that's where this new approach
that I've taken with with the economists
with Peter Phillips and others in the
Economics Department that's where this
new approach comes in so we've started
out we've taken a major step back and we
started out with a simple energy balance
we started out with the principle of
energy
taking into account the radiation budget
and and heat transferred within the
system and we've come up with this
equation for the temperature at a time T
plus 1 where T is in years at a given
location and and we find that that can
be related to based on these energy
balance principles that can be related
to the temperature of that location in
the previous year the radiation that we
should the surface at that location
short solar radiation that reached a
surface at that location in the previous
year and then a global term and the
global term has global temperature
global radiation reaching the surface
and and co2 and so we have 1,300
locations where we have constructed this
this equation here and we feed it
observations for each of these locations
so the observations are incoming solar
radiation from this global energy
balance archive the giba dataset that
has been measuring solar radiation
reaching the surface with with
instruments around the globe going by
the earliest earliest measurements start
in 1920 but we were really able to get
good coverage only after 1964 so our
analysis starts in 1964 we also have
temperature data for each station from
the had crew data set and we have
equivalent co2 data from the annual
greenhouse gas index and so what we've
done is you know for the 1300 equations
that we had for each location we fed up
to rate these observations into these
equations and we try to determine these
coefficients here and that's where my
collaborators in the Economics
Department come in because they then use
dynamic panel data methods to determine
these parameters that would allow us to
agree as as well as possible with the
observed at all these 1,300 stations
simultaneously and and so after
calculating the values of these
parameters that would allow us to do
that
as well as possible we came up with this
decomposition of the observed
temperature from 1964 to the present and
so the that equation with the estimated
parameters is that purple curve here and
observations for each individual year
are in in dots here and and you could
argue that the the simple approach with
the fitted parameters do a decent job at
least as well as as global climate
models I would argue what you can also
do then is with that same equation you
can set co2 constant at 1964 values and
only allow radiation to change I'm sorry
and you get this cooling because of the
period where you had dimming you had
downward trends in solar radiation and
then asked you transition to a
stabilization you don't get much of a
cooling anymore from aerosols and then
you can do the same thing by setting
radiation constant at 1964 levels and
then you get a much stronger warming
than what you actually got with a
combination of aerosols and and
greenhouse gases so that way we could
decompose the temperature trend into a
contribution from aerosols and a
contribution from from greenhouse gases
I really want to emphasize that we don't
think of this models anything that has a
predictive ability so you wouldn't dream
of using this to predict the future but
if we think of it as something that
could be used to try to understand the
past what you can also get out of this
this a very simple approach is you can
get out get out of this a climate
sensitivity if you get gamma 3 you get
us the sensitivity to cool in co2 okay
so we get this climate transient climate
sensitivity from gamma 3 times log 2 and
that gives us a climate transient
climates history of 3.4 Kelvin note
however that you can only think of this
as valid for the part of the World War
II how stations and essentially you
could think of it as valid for land only
and there's a 95% confidence
integral of that of that goes from two
calvin 24.8 health you could argue that
temperature change over land is much
more relevant for policy than global
mean temperature change but if you
wanted to translate this into a global
mean transit climate sensitivity we can
use the information that we have from
the temperature record knowing that land
has warmed roughly twice as much as the
oceans in in the temperature record in
the recent temperature record so then
you can translate that into a goal will
translate climate sensitivity of 2.2
kelvin with a confidence 95% confidence
into integral going from one point three
to three point one Kelvin so I put that
into this you you'll recognize this
figure you've seen it several times
today it shows the various estimates of
transient climate sensitivity from the
last IPCC report and I put our study
here and you can see that it our best
estimate is at the upper range about the
seam of five models for example predict
so the black histogram here is from the
seam up five models in our estimate is
really at the upper upper range of that
and it's much higher than for example
the recent paper by auto and co-workers
and nation Nature Geoscience where they
came up with the best estimate of 1.4
Kelvin for the transient climate
sensitivity so this is a purely
observational based approach to
estimating the transient climate
sensitivity that I'd love to have your
your feedback on finally I wanted to I
know I'm over time I would I wanted to
just talk briefly about the sensitivity
to the choice of time window because
there have been some studies coming out
recently that found a lot lower climate
sensitivity when they took this recent
period of the hiatus into account so we
wanted to see if we instead of those
that full forty six year time period we
chose a twenty five year rolling window
what kind of climates transmit climate
sensitivities could we get from that and
so if you choose this this time period
going from roughly the 60s to the 80s
you get somewhat lower climb climate
sensitivities because you had this
period where he wasn't really warming
much so then you get lower climates and
sensitivities then you move into this
period where we're where we got
accelerated warming and you get these
higher climate sensitivity estimates and
then if you choose the most recent
period you get something in between and
for the full period you see the the
distribution that comes out of that
rolling window approach and that brings
me to my conclusions so there is this an
intimate relationship between aerosol
cooling and climate sensitivity and it's
a problem that we can't constrain the
aerosol effect better because that means
that we can't constrain climate
sensitivity better in our models and
then finally this new approach that
we've taken the simple approach gives us
a transient climate sensitivity of about
2.2 Kelvin and it supports the higher
transit climate sensitivity estimates
that came out of Seema at 5:00 and then
finally uh I put this here as a reminder
for us all working on climate
sensitivity to do the press release
after we've had our papers to go through
peer review some of you may have seen
this in the Economist where they
published on some some papers by
Norwegian colleagues of mine Ashley and
and and the papers are have still not
gone through peer review and this was in
I it was early this year so with that
I'll end and take questions or actually
not